the 2011 Alumni medal for distinguished
service to Columbia University is
presented to mark moons in 1983 Columbia
College 1986 Columbia Law School the
most impactful thing for me coming to
Columbia in 1979 was my introduction to
music both as part of my education and
as part of my being a New Yorker for the
first time I was a bassoonist and
Columbia assigned me a teacher who was
the principal bassoonist of the
Metropolitan Opera and so you know yes
I'm a lawyer and I loved the practicing
law but I go back to those days when I
really had a formidable challenge to
practice and to play before a
world-class musician that to me was a
very unique and wonderful experience I
met my wife here I was in the law school
she was at si a now it's known as SEPA
and we met at a Columbia University
Armenian club meeting after I graduated
from law school I got active and the
alumni representative committee which is
charged with interviewing students who
apply to the College in the School of
Engineering I've been the chair of that
committee now coming up on 19 or 20
years nothing quite measures up to when
you actually meet someone he or she goes
and attends the school and then they
become active productive alumni the
Columbia University Club of Philadelphia
was founded by my dad Albert mom Jen and
several other Columbia alumni in 1979
and it was the first alumni club for
Columbia that was outside of the city of
New York and I've been president for
about six or seven years this was not a
Columbia College isolated Network it was
intended to be a university-wide network
my dad won the Columbia medal many years
ago and so I feel even a more special
connection because we're a
father-and-son team it puts us in a very
special category and I'm very very proud
of that
you